it's crazy what's happening right now  that this country one of the richest  countries in the world can't count  there's ballot boxes failing what in the  world is happening here come on  obviously we see NBA ABC News  gaslighting the fetterman campaign  gaslighting saying hey it's just going  to be a few days it's okay it's totally  normal totally fine no it's not it's not  okay it's not normal a lot of people  more than ever have have voted before  the election in early voting we should  be having a lot of these numbers up to  date when it happens when it comes in we  don't so of course A lot of people are  going to be skeptical a lot of people  are going to be asking themselves a lot  of serious questions but there's so many  different issues that I want to talk  about a Rothschild pass away passed away  on a red blood moon yo there's so many  crazy things happening